- Good morning, folks.
I just decided that I want to do another
What I Eat in a Day video.
I thought about the
one I did two years ago
and a lot has changed,
not only in my routine,
but also in my YouTube videos.
That one was just so cringe-y.
...energy to be utilized
throughout the day...
Ah, so I'm going to take you through
what I eat for breakfast, lunch, dinner,
and everything in between,
with the help of my partner, Lifesum,
who is going to help me track my calories,
macro nutrients, micro
nutrients, all that good stuff.
Are you ready to come along for the ride?
Gimme five, oh you
missed it, one more time.
No this hand, this one, gimme five, yeah!
My breakfast has changed a
little bit since my last video.
So let me show you what I
eat for breakfast nowadays.
This is my breakfast.
Lately, I haven't been eating breakfast.
I've become a huge fan
of intermittent fasting
where I have 14 to 16
hours since my last meal.
Like right now I'm about to
go on national television.
I have to be super sharp, talk about CBD,
kind of interesting.
If you guys want to hear more about CBD,
drop it down below in the comments.
I'm going to go on TV
without eating anything.
I feel sharper; I feel more engaged.
This is consistent with
some of the leading research
that's showing intermittent
fasting can be a good idea.
Now it's not right for everybody,
and I don't recommend you start it without
chatting with a doctor first,
but it certainly works for me.
I need a little caffeine kick
but I'm not a huge fan of overdoing it.
I drink my magic sauce,
and that's green tea.
- [Astronaut Voice]
Ignition sequence start:
six, five, four, three, two, one, zero.
All engines running.
- Now my fresh cup of tea is ready to go.
As I told you in my hot tea video,
you don't want to drink anything
that's above 140 degrees Fahrenheit.
So I do let it chill for a little bit
before I take a sip.
It gives me a nice little boost
with a tiny bit of caffeine
instead of that caffeine kick that I get
if I'm drinking a cup of coffee.
I need that sometimes,
but not most mornings.
Especially when I'm going on television,
I don't want to look crazy.
(voice playback at high speed)
All right I got this yummy bowl of steak,
sweet potatoes, broccoli.
Over here I got my avocado
toast with some sriracha flakes.
This bowl is a go-to bowl for me.
It has protein; It has
complex carbohydrates,
anti-oxidants from the broccoli.
And on top of it, it has romesco sauce:
olive oil, healthy fats.
You know they say you are what you eat.
I guess I must be nutritious.
I'm going to pull up my Lifesum app here
and enter what I ate.
Muti-grain...if I can spell...toast,
guacamole, single
potato, steak: grass fed.
So for lunch I've
already had 773 calories,
which is really close to my 800 goal.
The only thing is, my
sodium is quite high.
That's because I'm eating out.
There's a lot of sauces, there's
a lot of sodium in there.
I'm going to cut myself
a break on this one meal
and go 200mg over.
So you may have noticed, Bear is wearing
his in-training jacket.
The biggest reason he needs that jacket,
is just so inconsiderate dog owners
don't let their dogs just run up to him,
because some people think that all dogs
should just be playing
while they're on leash.
That is not the case.
Dogs need to respect other dogs' space
and that's part of teaching
your dog proper etiquette.
That's how you train a pup.
Now a lot of you may not know this,
but I'm pretty good at basketball.
Making it rain...Dr. J!
I've told you before that I like doing
all different types of
activities to stay fit.
Basketball is one of them.
If I can't find game, I'm
just going to go ahead
and just dribble by myself.
You know, I could play
one-on-one-on-one-on-one,
which is with my imaginary self.
Banks open on Tuesdays, folks.
All right, I'm about to grab my favorite
post-workout snack, it may surprise you.
Not a huge fan of post-workout shakes
because they make me feel bloated.
So I get some berries and mango.
This is like really good fiber, sugars,
to get that insulin
kick after your workout.
And then the magic
sauce, boiled whole eggs.
A lot of people don't like these,
'cause they think they're tasteless.
I think they're delicious.
Then, because I need some
electrolytes to refuel,
I'm gonna get some pink
Himalayan salt here.
Dip, get a little bit of
salt on there, just a pinch.
A lot of people say, oh I don't like it
without ketchup and mayo.
Look, if you need a dab of
ketchup or a dab of mayo
to make a healthy meal
appetizing, make it happen.
Just don't throw in a whole
three tablespoons of mayo
and expect that meal to still be healthy.
Now, I go into my favorite part.
Blueberries, one of the
most antioxidant rich
berries out there, one of
the best fruits to eat.
Hard boiled egg,
blueberries, strawberries,
and then last but not least mango.
Here's our stats: 334
calories, 17 grams of protein,
31 grams of carbs, 16 grams
of fat, 160mg of sodium.
Now the sodium might
be a little bit higher
'cause I did sprinkle a
little bit on my eggs,
but I think that's pretty
negligible at this point.
Now it's time for me take a shower,
kick back, relax a little bit with Bear,
maybe a little Netflix and
chill if you know what I mean.
Who Netflix's and chills with their dog?
He loves to wrestle.
Look at him, he just collapses.
I'm going to enjoy myself a Greek salad
with grilled chicken.
Greek salad is the way to go.
You're getting tomatoes,
cucumbers, olives,
all power vegetables.
You got your grilled chicken,
clean source of protein.
A little olive oil and vinegar,
just for the extra little taste kick.
After a long day, filming,
hanging out with Bear,
doing TV, this is a nice
thing to come home to.
And I'm gonna say, this is
roughly 8 ounces of chicken,
a small avocado, half a
tomato, 1 ounce of olive oil.
There was a little feta
in here, feta, feta.
We got 829 calories in this meal.
71 grams of protein, 22
carbs, 54 grams of fat,
all healthy fat, sodium
1216 which is under
what I'm supposed to be
eating for this meal.
And this is a perfect dinner for me,
at least for my goals.
Look at that feta, yum.
For those of you who have
not lived in Manhattan,
storage comes at a premium.
So when I get a lot of groceries,
I have to store them in, of all places,
in my dishwasher.
And I know that's really funny to say,
but I don't use the dishwasher a lot.
I order out a lot and
if I'm washing dishes
I can just do 'em by
hand in the dishwash...
In the dishwasher? No, in the sink.
What I do use it for
is for storing my nuts.
I love nuts; I'm actually not
joking I really do love nuts.
That's about half a cup.
I feel like you guys are going to be
judging me so hard for
using my dishwasher.
Look, my dishwasher is confused already.
It turned on because
it's like, is it time?
No, it's not time.
There's groceries inside
here, don't wash them.
Healthy fats galore here.
Even a little bit of protein
to finish off my day.
What I want you do understand
from watching me today,
having my final snack here,
this is what I ate today.
It's not what I eat everyday.
That's an important distinction.
And one of the most
important distinctions,
is that this diet that I follow,
this specific eating plan that I follow,
is not for everybody.
Now it's what works for me;
it's what I'm eating right now.
That may change, but again nutrition
has to be individualized.
It's different for person A, for person B,
and even person C.
I bet you didn't expect I was
throwing person C in there.
Bear likes hanging out with me
while I eat nuts, because
obviously bears love nuts.
I actually don't know if that's a thing.
I'm 49 calories over, which means that
I'm right in the right spot for calories.
I under ate my protein just a little bit,
but I over ate fats.
That's going to happen
on a day to day variance.
Remember, this is what
I eat in a day today,
not what I eat everyday.
There's going to be some variation.
A really simple take away for you:
decrease the refined sugars,
decrease the processed foods,
and increase the fruits and vegetables
and plants in your diet,
as well as those proteins,
'cause that's how you
stay happy and healthy.
And speaking of happy and healthy,
as always, Bear do you want to do it?
As always, stay happy and
healthy, coming from Bear.
And check out this video.